Savez-vous qu'on nous a menti à propos de la fraise ?
D'après les botanistes, les scientifiques
qui étudient les plantes,
c'est ce qu'on appelle un faux-fruit.
Comment est-ce possible ?
Au départ, il y a bien des fleurs,
un pistil, des étamines, du pollen.
Allez ! si vous êtes aux fraises avec cette
histoire, suivez-moi,
je vais vous dire toute la vérité sur la fraise.
Pour les botanistes, cet aliment
constitué de chair rouge…
et parfumé, n'est pas le fruit du fraisier,
c'est ce qu'on appelle un faux-fruit !
Les vrais fruits sont en fait les petits grains
jaunes, verts ou bruns
qui se trouvent à la surface.
Avec une loupe, on les voit mieux.
C'est ce que l'on appelle des akènes.
Chaque akène se présente sous la forme
d'une enveloppe qui renferme la graine.
Alors le fraisier n'est pas la seule plante
à produire des akènes.
C'est aussi le cas du hêtre du chêne avec ses
glands ou du châtaignier avec ces châtaignes.
Bref, d'un point de vue strictement botanique,
les fruits du fraisier sont là !
Et sur une seule fraise, il peut y en avoir
des dizaines, voire des centaines.
Tout dépend de la variété. Mais aussi de
son mode de culture.
Et la chair rouge alors,
c'est quoi ?
Et bien c'est le réceptacle de la
fleur qui s'est développé.
Allez, on retourne au jardin, il faut
que je vous montre quelque chose.
Voici des fraisiers que
j'ai planté au printemps.
On voit des fraises à différents stades de
développement, juste après la fleur.
Ici, elles sont encore vertes. Quant à celles-ci,
il va bientôt falloir la cueillir.
Sinon, ce sont les oiseaux qui vont se régaler.
Comme vous pouvez le constater, c'est une plante
herbacée qui pousse au ras du sol.
Contrairement au pommier ou au cerisier,
elle ne pousse pas dans un verger
mais dans un potager habituellement
à côté des tomates ou des radis.
Bon, ici, il n'y en a pas !
Comme l'herbe, les fraisiers peuvent facilement
s'étendre et envahir le jardin.
Les fraisiers produisent des tiges qu'on appelle
des stolons d'où vont partir des racines.
C'est exactement ce qui s'est passé ici.
J'ai planté des fraisiers l'année dernière et cette
année, un nouveau est sorti de terre.
Enfin, à nouveau, une prolongation du pied mère,
c'est ce qu'on appelle le marcottage.
Alors les fraisiers pousse très bien ici,
c'est tout à fait logique, car au XIXème siècle
ce jardin était celui d'un fraisiériste autrement, dit celui d'une personne qui produisait des plants de fraisiers.
À l'origine, cette plante herbacée poussait à l'état
sauvage, comme les fraises des bois.
Vous savez, ces toutes petites fraises qui se cachent dans les fourrés et les talus, à la lisière des bois.
Je ne sais pas si
vous en avez déjà cueilli
mais il faut chercher longtemps pour en trouver
suffisamment pour faire une tarte ou un pot de confiture.
Du coup, il n'y a plus rien à voir ici.
Allez direction l'atelier !
La première trace de culture de fraises en France
remonte à 1324, dans un hôpital à Arras, dans le Nord.
Les fraises à l'époque, étaient cultivées
pour leurs vertus médicinales.
On utilisait les feuilles, les racines
ou les fruits sous forme de tisane
de sirop ou de pommade pour soulager le mal de
gorge, les douleurs aux reins et même les fractures.
Et puis, petit à petit, la gourmandise a pris le dessus.
Et en 1368, quand les fraises sont cultivées
dans les jardins royaux du Louvre,
ce n'est plus pour leurs vertus médicinales,
mais plutôt pour leur goût !
Hum.
Que c'est vrai que c'est bon !
Aujourd'hui, on trouve une multitude
de variétés sur nos étals.
Aller en cuisine.
Des fraises, il y en a des grosses, des
petites, des rondes, des allongées,
Elles ont un goût sucré ou acidulé,
même leur couleur peut changer.
On les préfère souvent bien rouges, mais certaines sont carrément blanches.
Oui mais ça, c'est quand elles ne sont pas mûrs !
Non, c'est la couleur naturelle de cette variété,
comme il y a des pommes vertes, rouges ou jaunes.
La variété la plus répandue en France, c'est la Fragaria X Ananassa de son petit nom latin.
Ananassa parce que le botaniste qui l'a décrite en 1766, un certain Monsieur Duchesne, lui a trouvé un goût d'ananas.
En fait, la Fragaria Ananassa est le fruit du croisement de 2 variétés sauvages de fraises venues d'Amérique.
La fraise du Chili et la fraise de Virginie.
Le mariage a eu lieu au XVIIIe siècle grâce à un homme au nom prédestiné, Amédée François-Fraisier.
D'où le nom de la plante
Pas du tout justement, fraise s'écrit FRAISE.
C'est un dérivé de fragaria, de Fraga,
qui signifie fraise des bois.
Alors que le nom du personnage s'écrit FREZIER.
Ah, d'accord, c'est donc le fruit du hasard !
Oui, mais si tu ramène tout le temps ta fraise,
comment veux tu que je finisse mon histoire moi.
Car vous allez voir, la fraise a bien failli nous passer sous le nez.
Amédée-François-Frézier. Ce Monsieur a été envoyé au Chili au début du XVIIIe siècle par Louis XIV.
Sa mission : espionner les fortifications espagnoles.
Monsieur Frézier, qui est aussi botaniste amateur,
occupe son temps libre à étudier la flore locale.
Il est alors stupéfait par la taille des fraises
qu'il voit là-bas
Bien plus grosses et parfumées que les fraises
des bois que l'on consomme en Europe.
A son retour en 1714.
Il rapporte quelques plans en France, qu'il décide de cultiver dans le potager de sa propriété située à Plougastel, en Bretagne.
C'est au sud de Brest, à l'entrée de ce que
l'on appelle la pointe de l'Armorique.
C'est très joli, pour ceux qui connaissent.
Bonne nouvelle, une fois en terre, les plants survivent.
Mauvaise nouvelle, ils ne donnent aucun fruit.
Malgré ses connaissances en botanique, Frézier n’a rapporté que des plans sans étamine
c'est-à-dire, des fraisiers sans appareil reproducteur mâle.
Ces pauvres plans, tous femelles, sont donc incapables de se féconder seul et de fructifier.
Mais l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là, et heureusement pour nous.
Quelques années plus tard, de grosses fraises parfumées apparaissent sur les fraisiers.
C'est surtout grâce à la petite brise bretonne.
Les plans ramenés du Chili par Frézier
ont été planté à côté de plans de Virginie
rapportés en France quelques décennies
plus tôt, par d'autres voyageurs.
Les fraisiers Virginiens, avaient eux, des étamines dont le pollen
a pu féconder les fleurs des fraisier du Chili.
Et c'est ainsi que la fraise ananas est née,
caractérisée par ses gros fruits parfumés et fermes.
La Bretagne est alors devenue la principale région
productrice de fraises jusqu'au milieu du XXe siècle.
Et aujourd'hui, il existe de nombreuses variétés de
fraises que je vais vous présenter.
Celles qui tiennent le haut du panier de courses sont la Gariguette, la Ciflorette, la Charlotte, la Mara des bois.
Ces différentes variétés ont été créées par des
chercheurs et des ingénieurs agronomes.
La Gariguette, par exemple, tient son nom du chercheur qui a mis au point cette variété
et qui habitait "Chemin des Gariguettes", dans le Vaucluse.
Certaines variétés, appelées remontantes,
produisent plusieurs fois dans l'année.
On peut manger leurs fruits jusqu'aux premières
gelées et on ne s'en prive pas.
En France, on en produit 60 000 tonnes chaque année
et les Français en dévorent entre 2 et 3 kilogrammes
par personne et par an.
Sympa tes histoires, mais comment on les déguste ?
Les fraises sont très fragiles, mieux vaut les déguster
le jour même au retour des courses.
Rincez-les juste avant de les consommer sous un petit filet d'eau sans les faire tromper et retirer la queue et la collerette.
Après le rinçage, l'eau leur fait perdre du goût, mieux vaut qu'elle ne pénètre pas au coeur des tissus.
Ensuite, c'est une histoire de goût.
Pour moi, c'est plutôt nature, ou alors un peu plus sophistiqué.
Je vais vous montrer.
Ça fait de jolis cristaux verts, c'est beau et...
c'est délicieux...
Et vous, comment les préférez-vous ?
Dites-le moi en commentaire.
Et cerise sur le gâteau, les fraises ne sont
pas seulement goûteuses,
elles sont aussi gorgées de vitamine C et de vitamine B9.
En plus, elles sont très peu caloriques.
Elles contiennent seulement 33 kcal pour 100 g, presque 2 fois moins que les poires et 3 fois moins que les bananes.
D'ailleurs, la petite caméra t'a préparé une surprise.
Des fraises Chantilly avec un peu de sucre à la coriandre.
Pour le parfum, si si, mais tourner dessus.
Ah bon ?
Ah c'est malin...
Allez, à bientôt les Épicurieux !
Et bonnes fraises !
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Merci les Épicurieux.
Pour les plus gourmands, en voici d'autres. Et pour ne rien rater, abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.